[Applause]
after germany's most significant general
election in years
the country's vice chancellor olef
scholz is tasked with brokering a
coalition deal
his centre-left social democrat party
narrowly took first place in the vote
but not by enough to put them in power
two much smaller parties the greens and
the liberal fdp
will be key to the three-way coalition
needed to form a government
the economist's editor-in-chief zanny
minton bedos was joined by berlin bureau
chief tom nuttall and jurg lao did sites
foreign policy coordinator to discuss
what the results of the election mean
for the future of germany
the departure of chancellor merkel in
itself is a pretty momentous event for
germany and indeed for europe but the
results of this election will change a
lot or will they what will they mean for
germany what will they mean for europe
and what are the wider implications for
the rest of the world the most exciting
new development is is the greens and the
ftp
uh being king makers so that's a really
new development that we haven't seen
before because they they come from
different milieus they the people who
vote for them don't especially like each
other
so um there is a lot to be overcome
there the two traditional people's
parties the union and the spd they got
around about half of the vote and that
number has been going down and down and
down and down over the years as it has
done in other countries but i think
what's different in germany is that that
fragmentation has not come at the
expense of the political center
considered its broadest sense so we've
already spoken about how the fdp and
particularly the green party did well
the share of the seats that the
extremist parties if you want to call
them that the afd on the right and
de-linker on the left the share of seats
that they will have in the bundestag has
shrunk so what you see is a
strengthening of the political center in
germany despite the fragmentation and
that i think is a distinct german story
that you don't necessarily find in other
european countries that have experienced
political fragmentation
in the end these negotiations are about
characters and who's going to lead so um
maybe jurg let's start with you because
olaf schultz who is uh the chancellor
candidate of the spd and thus
currently the man tipped to be the most
likely next chancellor he was the mayor
of hamburg where you are give us a quick
pen portrait you know him what's he like
he's a very calm rational guy
he likes to present himself as the safe
pair of hands and
in the social democratic spectrum he's
someone who
was a reformist with a gerhard schroeder
very much in favor of the reforms of the
welfare state
that were not popular with social
democrats and he's come a long way in in
um yeah um embracing
a little bit more of a left-wing agenda
but still
um presenting it uh in a very rational
calm way so it's not to scare off any
uh any voters so i'd like to turn now to
the international implications of this
vote in the post-merkel era which is the
one we're going to now
what will change in terms of germany's
role in the world well one factor is
that the next chancellor whoever it will
be
will be
a somewhat weaker figure than mrs merkel
from everything we just pointed out uh
the more fragmented political landscape
the
uh
the three-way coalition
um
so
this might mean that um
the bargaining power of germany on the
european stage might also
be somewhat diminished if we get a green
foreign minister
and
a social democratic chancellor we might
have a very interesting tension the
greens have somewhat tougher positions
on russia and china they were very very
critical about north stream too the
pipeline
uh connecting germany to to russia's gas
um
and olaf schultz
and also army russia were very very
supportive of this project so
it's it's going to be very interesting
to see how this plays out the
interesting thing about german coalition
agreements is that they're incredibly
detailed and the parties lay out what
their view is on all kinds of policy
matters and they lay out you know
specific tax policies spending policies
all manner of things but the problem
with foreign policy is that events
happen you know the americans leave
afghanistan at short notice you know
something happens and you can't
presumably write a coalition agreement
that foresees every possible thing that
could happen in the next few years where
is germany going to end up in your view
vis-a-vis russia and then vis-a-vis
china
russia i think is really a kind of a
problem to be managed something to be
contained um angela merkel held together
the eu which imposed sanctions on russia
after its um annexation of crimea the
invasion of eastern ukraine um a few
years ago and those sanctions have held
ever since i see no reason for the next
chancellor whoever it is
to change to change course on that the
chinese question i think is much more
complicated and probably in the long run
much more important um angela merkel of
course throughout her time as chancellor
um had an engagement first policy um
with china i think she was fascinated by
its rise she's sometimes accused of just
being a mechanicalist you know
subjecting german foreign policy to its
um trading relationship with china
certainly german exporters did very well
out of the rise of china but i think
there was more to the merkel line than
mercantilism i think what she wanted to
do um and it was a reasonable uh is a
reasonable thing to want um was to
figure out a way to fold china into the
multilateral system she didn't think
that you could contain china's rise but
i think that she thought that there was
a role for germany in trying to manage
it now that line has come under
increasing criticism inside germany and
of course outside germany in recent
years and i think there's now a
consensus at least in some parts of the
german establishment that this
relationship with china is going to have
to be recalibrated on almost every
single front yeah do you agree with that
i think there is um
a lot of rethinking has to be done on
the part of the social democrats about
their
concept of engagement coming from the
old idea of us politik
from the cold war
changed through trade
we've never been closer
with with china than today uh in terms
of trade
but it hasn't uh amounted to a lot of
opening up of the chinese society quite
to the contrary i will stick my neck out
there and i think that this area is one
area where
it will take a while but german german
policy will change really quite
substantially towards china in the next
few years in large part because of what
is happening in china and how germany is
realizing what is happening in china i
think it's going to become a much more
pressing concern for the next chancellor
not because they will want it to be but
because events will force it on them i
think this will be the biggest foreign
policy test for the next german
government
hi that was part of the digital event
produced exclusively for subscribers to
the economist if you'd like to watch the
full conversation please click the link
you'll just have to register with the
economist if you haven't already or you
can subscribe to enjoy all of our
journalism thanks for watching